[Музика]
тому, хлопці, я знову радий бачити вас у своєму
класі,
ми продовжуємо говорити про спорт, тому ця
дошка неможлива без
здоров’я сьогодні, ми поговоримо про
здоров’я та як зберегти здоров’я, перш ніж
почати  Говорячи про травми здоров'я,
хвороби та деякі неприємні речі, ми
повинні говорити про частини хлопчика,
подивіться на малюнок і вкажіть
на частини тіла, давайте переглянемо наші частини тіла,
так що це за рука обличчя вуха рот
шия живіт коліно і нога потім прийде
лікоть ніс і очі подивіться на нього
рука голова рука рука назад внизу або сідниці
і нога, звичайно, є ще інші
частини тіла, але це основні,
тому давайте спробуємо ще раз, що це
правий лікоть, а це
попереду  це спина і ще один цей
і коліно добре, тому частини тіла
дуже корисні, коли ми говоримо про ідіоми
, ви пам'ятаєте ідіоми з
попередніх уроків добре подивіться ось у
нас є деякі нові подивіться
на перші  se  ntence у
Мері є солодощі, що це
означає, можливо, це означає, що один із
зубів Мері має порожнину, означає дірку,
або Мері любить торти та
солодощі, або останній батько Мері
дуже мила дівчина, то що б ви хотіли
оберіть
пам’ятайте, що ідіоми не мають прямого
значення, тому це правильно, це
означає, що Марія любить
торти та солодощі, особисто я не
люблю солодощів, я краще з’їм
щось кисле чи солоне, аніж друге
– нове  машина коштувала б мені ока, як
це можливо, це коштувало б мені ока, так
що перший варіант я не можу дозволити собі нову
машину, вони занадто дорогі або я не можу
керувати новими автомобілями через ліжковий зір
або дуже погано, я думаю, що ви
дійсно красиві, так що  як ти думаєш, що
ти не можеш собі це дозволити, ти не можеш керувати автомобілем О
, вони красиві правильна відповідь:
я не можу дозволити собі в твоїй машині, я не можу цього зробити,
вони занадто дорогі, ок,
наступний Боб тягне тебе за ногу, чому так  Боб
тягне за ногу наша домініка не
ді  прямо так, що це означає Боб хоче, щоб
ви вірили в його брехню Боб хоче
привернути вашу увагу чи Боб є
мануальним терапевтом, то що б ви вибрали, я
думаю, що це Боб хоче, щоб ви вірили в
його брехню, добре, давайте далі, тому я думаю, що
його пульт  повинен був бути
язик-на-щічним
язивом, що він зауважив, що його зауважив, що його зауваження не повинно бути
занадто серйозно, або його зауваження повинно
залишатися хворим
Бреттом Що ви думаєте  in-cheek
означає, що це жарт, можливо, не дуже
хороший, можливо, саркастичний, але все ж
жарт, тому це означає, що його позначку не
слід сприймати надто серйозно ще раз, якщо вам
потрібно записати ці ідіоми, щоб
мати ласуни  любити
торти та цукерки тоді коштує, а я означаю
бути дуже дорогим, ніж тягнути за ногу,
означає змусити когось повірити у твоє
життя, а жартівливість означає жарт,
можливо, дурний, тому ні, ми дійдемо до
травм і  хвороби і хвороби,
на жаль, люди можуть стати
нездоровими і  нам потрібно знати, як
впоратися з цією неприємною ситуацією,
подивіться на слова, які вам потрібно, щоб
доповнити текст правильною формою
ви повинні вибрати зміну, це може бути
зі слів у полі, якщо вам потрібен
словник, ви можете  використовуйте це добре, тож
ось слова кашель, а потім грип біль
біль температура та вірус у нас є дві
ситуації з двома дітьми Керін і Піт
пам’ятайте, можливо, вам доведеться змінити
форму дієслова чи іменника,
тому подивіться на  історія Карен,
давайте прочитаємо, Карен зараз не дуже гарна, у
неї дуже сильна застуда або,
можливо, це не в цьому світі, вам
потрібен іменник,
знайдіть іменник і напишіть, що
вона весь час літає, і тепер вона має
throat in be вам потрібен дієслово, тому що
дієслова завжди стоять на другій позиції
в реченні, тому вона давайте знайде дієслово
з пташки слів і вона
постійно кушає, і тому тепер у неї є тепер
вам потрібен прикметник fine place the
прикметник вона наближається, у неї болить
горло і ще раз  давайте повернемося до
того, що вона кашляє, вона кашляє, нам потрібно залучити
нас, тому що це зараз просто, тому що вона
добре ще раз давайте прочитаємо всю
історію. Карен зараз не дуже добре,
вона дуже сильно застудилася або,
можливо, це грип, вона все кашляє
час і тому ні, у неї болить горло,
добре, давайте подивимося на історію Піттса. У
Піта дуже висока температура, і вам
потрібен іменник, тому у нас є ще кілька іменників
і нам потрібна температура. У Піта дуже
висока температура тридцять дев'ять балів  п'ять
градусів дуже високо, у нього знову щось є,
вам потрібен іменник у нього щось
в руках і ногах, і слово біль
ідеально підходить, у нього болять
руки і ноги, і останнє слово,
можливо, це вірус, тому що багато
людей хворі  зараз у школі
давайте ще раз прочитаємо всю історію у
Піта дуже висока температура 39
балів п'ять градусів,
у нього болять руки та ноги,
можливо, це вірус, тому що багато
людей зараз хворіють у
школі добре, у мене є кілька
ques  ви легко застуджуєтесь що
ви робите, щоб їх зупинити хм, це дуже
неприємна ситуація, коли ви
застуджуєтеся, особливо коли погода така
гарна,
то що мені робити, щоб зупинитися і не
застудитися хм, особисто я намагаюся харчуватися
здорово  дієта Я намагаюся робити вправи
щодня і, звичайно, намагаюся
уникати публічних місць, коли є якісь
проблеми з вірусами або грипом, як
сезонний грип. Друге питання, чи
травмуєтеся ви коли-небудь, займаючись спортом або
іншими видами діяльності, які є спортом
іноді найнебезпечніше спортсмени або
спортсмени можуть мати різні травми,
іноді, коли ми граємо або займаємося спортом, ми
можемо собі пошкодити, це дійсно
неприємно, але може статися, щоб уникнути
цієї ситуації, ви повинні бути готові
тренуватися з особистим тренером або в
команді і будь ласка  будьте дуже уважні до
свого здоров'я, давайте рухатися далі, тому я хочу, щоб
ви закінчили речення
теперішньою досконалою формою дієслів, даними
запам'ятати, коли ми минулого разу говорили про цей
час і ми грали  Kahoot так, що в
наявному досконалому він має плюс третя
форма дієслова, так що перша я, щоб
вивчати медицину, що б ви вибрали і
якою була б ваша відповідь Я
вирішив вивчати медицину наступне
речення мій друг dr.  Люсі Сміт, мій
друг, це він, тому я знаю, що це має
бути на третьому класі – зустріти Метта Метта,
тому мій друг зустрів доктора.  і Люсі
Сміт наступний, який ми вивчали історію
спортивної зірки D, зірка зробив Y змінився на I,
і ми йому допомогли, тому ми вивчили
історію спорту наступний у мене не було
жодних нещасних випадків, о, мені потрібна негативна
форма, тому я прийшов
у мене не було аварій або повна форма. У мене не було жодних
нещасних випадків, наступне питання, тож
якщо це питання, ви маєте або маєте потребу
перейти на першу позицію, тож, тато, це
він, то що ми маємо тут  твій тато
працював у лікарні, а останнє
речення моя сестра, моя сестра, це вона, тому мені
потрібно, щоб моя сестра стала медсестрою
, це
так, тому ми мудрі, тепер ідеальний подарунок.
Я б хотів, щоб ви писали запитання та запитували
свого партнера, чи  у вас є ти, якщо з тобою є
хтось поруч, або ти можеш задати
ці запитання, тоді команди нашого
уроку, тому залишайся в ліжку через грип, ти
повинен починати речення з чи
ти коли-небудь давайте спробуємо я маю на увазі це для вас, щоб
подумати, якщо ви  потрібно, щоб ви могли записати це
добре, так що ви коли-небудь застудилися
так  У мене я людина добре, у
наступного дуже висока температура
О, неприємна ситуація, безперечно, то
як би ви поставили це питання, у вас
коли-небудь була дуже висока температура,
звичайно, я маю
Привіт, наступний прийми ліки, які
дуже погані на смак я  не люблю приймати
Метсона, тому що дуже часто все на
смак добре, тож як би ви
поставили це питання добре, давайте перевіримо, чи приймали ви коли-
небудь ліки, які дуже погані на смак,
звичайно, у мене є, і останній зламав
вам руку мм-хм, так що ви  зробив
третю форму зламав тобі руку добре, давайте
перевіримо, чи ламав ти коли-небудь руку, на
щастя, я не зламав жодної руки чи
ноги, я задоволений цим,
добре, тепер подивіться на цього Далека, і
ви помітите, що помітите щось
дуже цікаве
подивіться, щоб інтерв'юер
мав коли-небудь настільки серйозні аварії, так, у
нього є інтерв'юер, експерт про те, що сталося експертом
це було в 1986 році, він впав з кількох метрів
і вдарився головою об камінь, а
там дві тонни змішано в одному діалозі
відповіді  запитання, які ви бачите нижче,
перше запитання – це перше
запитання доповідача в минулому простому чи
теперішньому досконалому давайте подивимося на
перше запитання, чи
був у нього коли-небудь добре, яка ймовірність того, що це
правильно, що є ідеальним друге
запитання чи про
загальний досвід або конкретний момент
у минулому загальний досвід або
конкретний момент ну перше
запитання інтерв'юера стосується загального
досвіду, а
не конкретного моменту в минулому, тепер
давайте подивимося на наступне
запитання доповідача друге запитання в
минулому просте  або теперішній досконалий давайте
подивимося на друге питання, так
що трапилося правильно, що було в минулому,
а останнє
питання стосується загального досвіду
чи конкретного моменту в минулому, а саме
про цей конкретний момент у минулому
в  минуле і подивіться, відповідь
починається з 1986 року. Точний
момент, тепер ми повинні знайти
різницю між використанням  past
Simple та Present Perfect Тож коли ми
використовуємо simple past, перший раз, коли ми
використовуємо просте минуле, щоб говорити про
дії, які не здійснюються з
теперішнім, це означає, що вони відбуваються десь
у минулому та в цей період часу, і
це займає  подивіться на приклад, коли Титанік
затонув у 1912 році, у нас є точна дата, і
це в минулому
. Другі дії використання в минулому
в хронологічному порядку,
хронологічно впорядковані, як у казці,
як у казці, або як, коли ви
говорите про своє вчорашнє  наприклад, він
прийшов, сів на диван і почав
чекати, тому всі дії відбувалися після
кожного, тому наступна – це повторювані
дії в минулому,
ми також можемо використовувати для повторюваних дій,
наприклад, я проходив курси англійської мови, коли
мені було 12 років, це означає, що  три рази на
тиждень або чотири рази на тиждень я ходив на
спеціальні курси, коли мені було 12, іншими
словами, я можу сказати, що колись відвідував курси англійської
дитина або
я ходив плавати, коли я був дитиною,
наступний раз, коли після розмови про
загальний досвід ми розповімо подробиці,
наприклад, я був у Лондоні цього місяця
я зупинився у великому готелі, я відвідав
Трафальгарську площу і купив кілька
сувенірів.  Загальний досвід полягає в тому, що
я був у Лондоні, але що конкретно
де я зупинявся, що я відвідав і що я
там купив, коли у вас є ці
запитання, де коли, чому і як, і якщо
ви говорите про минулі події, вам потрібно
використовувати past simple, добре, так  другий
аспект цієї теми, коли ми використовуємо
present perfect take a look, коли ми говоримо
про загальний досвід, не надаючи
конкретної інформації, ми не
знаємо, коли щось сталося, але ми
хочемо знати, чи це дійсно сталося,
подивіться на приклади  Тарантіно був
режисером багатьох блокбастерів, це
загальна інформація, що він ще живий, він,
можливо, зрежисує інші, але Тарантіно
зняв «Убити Білла» у 2003 році, у нас є
точна дата, і ця подія
вже в порядку  а наступний приклад я ніколи не
бачив Ейфелеву вежу
добре це загальний досвід я все ще
живий, можливо, одного дня я поїду в Париж і
побачу це, але я не бачив Ейфелеву вежу,
коли був у Франції, тут у нас є
точний час, коли я був у Франції,
можливо, я відвідав інші міста і не побував у
Парижі наступний приклад Джек написав
сценарій ось сценарій ось Джек
ось результат, який він написав
сценарій, але він зробив це  creep минулого
тижня ось у нас є точний час, коли
він зробив це минулого тижня добре, давайте
продовжимо другі дії використання, які
закінчені в минулому, але пов'язані
з сьогоденням ви можете побачити результат
ви пам'ятаєте Джека з його
сценарієм подивіться  у прикладі я склав
три тести цього семестру, тому цей
семестр ще не закінчений, він все ще
триває, але є результат три
тести, тоді, коли ми хочемо виразити
незавершений період часу, який почався
в минулому, але триває дотепер  подивіться
Хелен була в Лондоні  одного разу в її
житті твоє кохання не закінчилося, воно
все ще триває, можливо, одного дня вона знову поїде
до Лондона, а мої бабуся і дідусь
бачили Гамлета цього тижня, цей тиждень
не ввійшов, тому вони можуть знову піти в
театр і побачити це  ще раз,
можливо, це станеться на цьому тижні ще не
закінчено, все ще триває добре, тому
підводячи підсумок всього, що ми щойно сказали, нам
потрібно знати, що якщо є минулі
дії, які відбувалися в минулому і
мають результат на даний момент, вони присутні  ідеально,
коли ви знаєте, коли відбулася дія,
ви знаєте точну дату, ви знаєте
точний час, коли
проміжок часу не закінчився,
наприклад, сьогодні або цей тиждень,
він ідеальний, коли ви говорите про
свої минулі події про своє вчорашнє  або
про ваш останній тиждень, який ви використовуєте past simple
я встав я снідав
пішов до школи і так далі, тепер я думаю,
що ви готові трохи потренуватися, тому
цього разу я не буду показувати вам відповіді
відразу, я хочу, щоб ви написали  їх
вниз і т  тоді ми обговоримо їх,
тож подивіться на перше запитання чи
твердження. Я бачу цей фільм до того, як я побачу
цей фільм раніше, не є загальним чи це
конкретне, добре
, ви записали це добре, тоді ми
три книги з англійської мови в третьому класі
англійська  книги, схоже, результат
добре, так що ви написали свою відповідь,
ви перевірите себе пізніше злочин
наступний моя мама двічі в Лондон цього
року цього року двічі цього року не
закінчився так добре,
наступний Джон позичи у мене чотири компакт-диски
Джон запозичує добре загальний досвід
чи ні в наступному
сніданок для дітей добре, ти написав
свою відповідь добре випив каву
добре і мовчи, фільм добре, і знаю, що у
вас є час перевірити свою відповідь,
тому перший я  я бачив цей фільм
раніше, це загальний досвід, ми
прочитали три книги англійською мовою в класі,
тому це результат, що
моя мама була в Лондоні двічі цього
року,
добре, цього року ще не закінчено, тоді
Джон позичив у мене чотири компакт-диски.
згадується потім діти з'їли
час сніданку не згадується тільки
результат діти не голодні ви
знову випили всю каву
результат немає кави
і
мовчіть фільм почався ми не знаємо
часу, тому всі ці речення в  які
тонни є ідеальними, це зараз
я хочу, щоб ви змінили їх на минуле
просто, можливо, вам потрібно щось додати,
наприклад, я бачив цей
фільм раніше, але мені не сподобалося, він був
нудним, тому я зробив ще два речення
та використав  past Simple та розповіли про
конкретну ситуацію, тож у командах до
цього уроку, будь ласка, напишіть свої
речення, але змініть їх на минуле
просте, ми розпочнемо наступний урок,
перевіряючи ваші відповіді та розповідаючи про
те, як перетворити ці речення
на минуле просте  дякую за урок,
хлопці, ви чудові, побачимось наступного разу
[Музика].